[موسيقى]
اخترع اداه استخدمت في الحروب العسكريه
وشكلت عماد القوه النورانيه الحديثه
المهندس والكيميائي السويدي الفريد نوبل
مخترع الديناميت في العالم
ولد في العام
1833 في العاصمه السويديه ستوكهولم لابوين
فقيرين
انتقل نوبل مع اسرته الى سانت بطرسبورغ
حيث عمل والده في صناعه متفجرات
برع نوبل منذ صغره في دراسته لاسيما في
الكيمياء واللغات وكان يتحدث اللغات
الانجليزيه والفرنسيه والالمانيه والروسيه
بطلاقه
درس الكيمياء مع البروفيسور ثم انتقل الى
باريس وعندما اكمل 18 سنه ذهب الى
الولايات المتحده لدراسه الكيمياء
حصل الفريد على اول براءه اختراع له عن
عداد الغاز عام 1857
بعد عوده نوبل من روسيا الى السويد رفقه
والديه كرس نفسه لدراسه المتفجرات فاخترع
هناك جهاز تفجير وصمم ايضا كبسوله التفجير
اخترع نوبل الديناميت عام
1867 وفي العام
1875 اخترع نوبل الجلجانيت وهي ماده اكثر
استقرارا وقوه من الديناميت
انتخب نوبل عضوا في الاكاديميه الملكيه
السويديه للعلوم في
1884 وهي نفس المؤسسه التي تقوم باختيار
الفائزين الاثنين من جوائز نوبل التي اوصى
بتاسيسها في وقت لاحق وحصل على الدكتوراه
الفخريه من جامعه اوبسالا في 1893
خلال حياته اصدر نوبل 350 براءه اختراع
دوليه وقبل وفاته قام بانشاء 90 مصنع
للاسلحه
اثار نعي خاطئ لصحيفه فرنسيه عن موت نوبل
حفيظه العالم الكيميائي وبدا يشعر بخيبه
امل جر اختراع لمواده تستخدم في القتل وهو
ما كان دافعا له بان اوصى باغلب ثروته
لتاسيس جوائز نوبل التي تمنح سنويا دون
تمييزا لجنسيه الفائز
عان نوبل من ذبحه صدريه وتوفي في منزله
جراء نزيف دماغي سنه
ودفن في ستوكهولم
[موسيقى]